I can't believe this is your 100th film
I'm sure everyone's asking you about
this but why do you think Marlo is the
perfect film to kind of complete this
career milestone for you
um that's a good question I I guess I'd
have to go back to
being 10 11 years of age
watching or a little black on my TV
on Sunday afternoon sometimes and and
usually I'm free bookard or Alum Ladd
and it was usually a film noir
but a detective
[Music]
certainly with Bogart it was uh
I think it was the big sleep
ING with marlonian which will be trench
coats Ray
Shadow despite
rookie characters Shady characters
uh
cynicism as thick as smoke yeah and uh
and you're trying to think oh he's the
bad no no he's about yes she's the bad
guy he's about I was just it was very
intriguing and um and
I I was glued to the TV setup you know
um so it's nice at the age of 70 to like
we shot the film when I was 69. yeah
that's incredible
um you have this thing with dying Kruger
that I love so much she says you're very
perceptive and sensitive I imagine it
gives you trouble are you like that in
any way in real life
I like I like to think I'm sensitive
because by
by the number of years I've lived and
experiences I've had and I've been in
this extraordinary industry
and telling of stories with remarkable
directors and remarkable actresses and
actors
and uh
and it hopefully it adds to a certain
Sensitivity I I would like to think I'm
sensitive you know yes oh you definitely
are and especially so many of the
characters that we just fall in love
with I know last time we spoke you're
really excited about a Naked Gun reboot
any updates on filming uh waiting on a
a rewrite of a potentially very good
script
so hopefully maybe this summer we'll
start yeah are you still excited about I
know you're a little bit nervous about
the comedy yeah I'm a bit nervous about
it but uh
um look it'll either end my school
career or no a new little chapter see
well just before I let you go I've
interviewed Helen Mirren a few times and
she always seems so lovely she recently
spoke about your past relationship and
said that she loves you deeply still to
this day and that you're such an amazing
guy what's your reaction to that she got
the check then
you paid her well
well Helen is uh it's a remarkable woman
remarkable actress I should be so lucky
and be honored to have spent three four
years with that lady
this is really something else
I love that listen always such a
pleasure getting to talk to you I really
loved you in this so congratulations
thanks Mark I appreciate it